denis demonpion éditorialiste politique
bonsoir denis demonpion merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france tout
d'abord sur ces rumeurs a relayé par le
monde d'un éventuel remaniement
gouvernemental on parlait même
éventuellement d'une dissolution de
l'assemblée d'un gouvernement de
concorde
telle est la réaction du du communicant
vous êtes écoutez je pense que
l'hypothèse d'une dissolution et je
pense à écarter totalement parce que on
avait vu la dernière dissolution décidée
par jacques chirac ça avait conduit à
une cohabitation avec l'avènement des
socialistes au pouvoir
en l'état actuel des choses le podium la
république n'aurait aucun intérêt
une dissolution en revanche un
remaniement
oui d'ailleurs fait qu'au cours de ces
interventions depuis le début de la
crise du vide 19 il a à plusieurs
reprises
encore lundi dernier d'ailleurs signalé
signifier qu' il y aurait des choses à
revoir et on peut penser qu'au sein du
gouvernement
compte tenu des ratés que lui-même
d'ailleurs à utiliser l'expression un
dératé de la cacophonie aussi espèce de
flou artistique en période aussi
dramatique a été véhiculée par divers
membres du gouvernement il est certain
et emmanuel macron prendra des décisions
alors les noms qui sont tannés qui sont
avancés évidemment pour entrer dans un
gouvernement
peut-on parler d'une y d'union nationale
pas vraiment parce que que ce soit
michel barnier que ce soit manuel valls
à part peut-être stéphane le foll se
sont quand même ils ont toujours fait un
peu cavalier seul quand même même s'il
était dans des écuries politiques nés on
peut penser que ils ont l'expérience
politique est en effet c'est ce qui fait
le plus grand défaut à
emmanuel macron depuis depuis le début
de son quinquennat donc effectivement il
serait temps que peut-être il renforce
par des poids lourds comme on dit ce
gouvernement
il faut rappeler aussi que manuel valls
lui a fait d'une certaine manière un
appel du pied puisque vous savez ils
étaient partis en espagne à barcelone
pour conquérir la ville de barcelone il
a échoué lamentablement
et aujourd'hui évidemment il considère
qu' il faut soutenir à toutes fins
emmanuel macron alors évidemment on sait
qu'ils ont été tous les deux dans le
gouvernement de françois hollande manuel
valls a été premier ministre emmanuel
macron était ministre des finances
on sait qu'ils ne se sont pas bien
entendu il y avait une vraie rivalité
pour le pouvoir entre les deux et on
peut penser que en pareille période ça
peut un peu s'atténuer rivalité donc
vous avez évidemment suivi l'allocution
du président avec sa stratégie de
déconfinement progressive où il a
abandonné 1 emmanuel macron ce
vocabulaire très guerrier c'est encore
très fou néanmoins il ya encore beaucoup
de questions après ce discours
écoutez il ya en réalité plus de
questions que de réponses
d'ailleurs on veut pour preuve
l'intervention du ministre de
l'éducation jean michel blanquer arrière
qui a dit que cette idée de
déconfinement réouverture des écoles des
crèches de la primaire etc jusqu'à
l'université vient collège-lycée après
le 11 mai serait discutée dans les
quinze jours qui viennent pourquoi parce
que évidemment autant le corps
enseignant a joué le jeu
pendant cette période de confinement et
ça avec les travaux les cours par
visioconférence et cetera et cetera
autant il serait exposé directement
à une éventuelle contractation de la
maladie s'il devait retrouver les
classes maintenant est ce que dans
l'esprit du président de la république
c'était de dire on renvoie les enfants à
l'école pour permettre aux parents de
travailler
il n'a pas été précis comme souvent
d'ailleurs il a laissé le flou le plus
artistique autour de cette déclaration
et il ya un autre problème qui va se
poser c'est que il ya évidemment des
personnes du clan enseignants qui
présentent des risques
on sait qu'elle fournit risque n'est ce
pas si on a des déficiences médical
s'ils en souffrent d'obésité etc etc
alors est ce que les enseignants ne font
pas valoir les éventuels problèmes de
santé qui l'ont et puis opposé un droit
de retrait que l'on se fait en france
c'est possible quand il ya un danger un
danger grave et imminent c'est la loi et
bien on peut demander à ne pas exercer
sa fonction le temps que ce danger grave
et imminent soit résorbée et comme le
président de la république à la même
façon lundi annoncé que cette épidémie
durer encore des mois il ya plus d
d'interrogation en effet sur l'issue de
cette la sortie de crise
merci beaucoup de ni de montant
éditorialistes politiques d'avoir été
avec nous